You are listening to Tu Tu Tu Tu Tu
for radio lab. This is radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
We're going to start today's program with a brief diversion to midtown Manhattan
at the office of a neuropsychologist.
Cameron Fallon bore a well dressed man with a calm voice,
calming presence and uncanny ability to comm others, which is why we're here.
Are you going to be the volunteer? Uh, yeah. I should actually check it. Yeah.
He walks me over to a small machine and asks for my left hand.
Have you ever left? Okay.
What we're doing right now,
we're just putting a couple of sensors that measure basically the flow of
electrons between two fingers here. That would be my index and middle fingers.
There are electrons going between my fingers. Oh absolutely.
There are salts and minerals that are going to enable a very tiny electrical
charge to travel from one finger to the other one.
And he explained to the more anxious I am,
the more sparks fly between my fingers. In other words, this is a stress test.
Okay, so I'm going to start at Miami or something.
You're not going to find anything,
but I will hear something that wine in the background. So if this goes up,
it means that you are more stressed.
So let me just make a couple of sounds here. You see,
stress me out man. Okay. Did you see that? Yeah.
Only with a couple of snaps near your ear. I got all the way to the top.
Yes, that's not good.
Well that means that you need to relax and break it down.
Techniques to bring stress down.
That is what Cameron Fallon poorer has promised us.
His theory is if you can hear your stress, you can control it. Okay,
so what I'd like you to do is just to sit back
and when you're ready, just go ahead and close your eyes.
And for now I'm going to actually get rid of the tone here for you.
You can monitor from here and I want you to just get as comfortable as you can
get right now
and gradually starting to take the slow breaths.
Will you ask them then?
Slow slowly
perhaps make your installation yes.
And more sustain.
Perhaps you can notice as you continue to breed slowly
that perhaps with each breath you feel a little bit more relaxed.
That bit more constant
[inaudible] for now there is nothing.
The phone rings now I'm all the way. Yeah. Yeah.
Isn't that appropriate? While you're trying to distress,
make your life a little better,
the phone rings runes it all one fell swoop like life. Really.
At any moment a dirty bomb could go off. You know this, you could get downsized,
dumped, dented by a med stroller pusher as you cross the street,
a street already swimming with naked hostility and fist sized avian flu bucks.
The point is the phone could ring at any time
getting more stressed. It's like
we can't control stress, but what we can do is understand it. Now,
if we lower the, uh,
lights today on radio lab conversations and stories about stress from many
different perspectives, starting with the science, when you are stressed out,
these things inside your digestion,
reproduction row with your heart rate change drastically and a leading
researcher will explain exactly how and later in the program,
very famous and perplexing case of stage fright.
It feels like somebody's you know, strangling you from the inside.
I'm Jad Abumrad riding shotgun with me is Mr Robert Krulwich. Oh,
who by the way,
immediately say that I think we should correct the prejudice here.
You seem to be anxious about stress. Well,
maybe a little bit stress is your friend.
We need it in midterms in eighth grade. If you didn't have a stress,
you wouldn't have gotten to ninth grade. You shouldn't just say, Oh God,
let's have less of it. Sometimes you want it to kick you in the button.
All right. I think our first story gets it. What you're saying.
It comes from a guy named Colby Hall. Colby,
tell me what you had for breakfast so I can set the levels. All right.
This morning I had a two hard boiled eggs and that Colby hall at a party
actually overheard him telling the story you're about to hear.
It's amazing story. So asked him to come in and tell to us in the studio. Now,
if you are squeamish,
you may want to consider turning the radio down for about seven minutes.
Does that sound sounds good to me and in your headphones. Good. All right, cool.
All right, Colby, let me start by asking you,
at what point in the story did you realize you were in big trouble that your
life was changing? When someone said get a tourniquet
[inaudible]
4th of July weekend up in Vermont, doubles tennis,
foothills of the green mountains, barbecues, beer lake.
It was perfect in every single,
and uh, we just said, let's, let's go water skiing.
So we load up the boat with towels and uh, you know,
we all get on there sort of excited to, you know,
kill an hour and a half on a beautiful lake on just a gorgeous, gorgeous day.
And just as we're sort of loading up the boat,
a canoe comes up to the dock and the in the canoe is this family,
this mother and father and their two little children and they were staying in a
house. And so we said, well, do you guys want to join us? Sure.
So the two little kids get in the boat and the father gets in the boat and we,
we pulled out from the dock and we get about 30 yards away from the dock and the
boat driver stops.
I have my little Waterski such devices belt on and it's kind of old school type.
And uh,
I jump off the side of the boat and the force of me getting in the water that
the Waterski belt falls off of me. No big deal. I'm just going to swim over.
And uh, I look up and the boat is closer to me than I had thought.
And it was actually moving towards me.
I guess with the driver had done is he may have thought he would put it in
neutral,
but in fact you put it in very slight reverse and he didn't know that I was
behind it. He was dealing with the, uh, the rope.
And so I'm in the water buckling the water belt and I look up and I notice,
and it's about 10 feet away from me. So I yell, Hey,
stop the boat. But it's a big boat. And you know, the wind is blowing and uh,
you know, your head is like sort of w level of the waters.
No one really heard me.
I couldn't move out of the way and it literally just came right up to me.
So I put my hands out to protect myself and uh,
immediately like I feel like these punches on my legs,
which was the boat propeller.
[inaudible]
people say living in the moment like you
it's amazing to me how many complex thoughts you have in a split second.
Wait, is this happening? Oh my God, it's happening. Wow.
This is cutting my legs. I'm trapped. I need to get out of this situation.
I'm going to push up, I'm going to go under the boat and let it go over me.
Like that all happened in a split second.
And at the same time you're thinking like,
maybe this will just be a bad injury or maybe I'll lose the use of one leg.
Here's all these sort of weird deals that you make in your head. Like,
I don't want to die so I'll just, you know,
be in a wheelchair or maybe I'll just be really,
really injured or maybe I'll never be at play basketball again.
Maybe I'll just always walk with a limp. You know, the other side of this,
this all happened one month to the day of my wedding.
He had planned this really,
I mean it was small but beautiful wedding upstate and uh, you know,
I want it to walk down the aisle. I want it to have the first answer.
And it sounds odd to explain that you're having all those thoughts and that time
that you are.
So I come up on the other side of the boat and a sort of gassed fare and I say
I'm hurt.
Okay.
It doesn't really hurt like you would, that was the weird thing.
Like it didn't hurt it just a,
I mean I feel it treading water and my legs are kind of numb.
I look up and my fiance is on the boat and she gets up and she sees me and she
can see that ring of blood surrounding me and the water up there is so clear
that she could see through the water.
She could see deep red tissue on my legs and big flaps of skin sort of hanging
off my legs floating with the motion of the water.
And it was at that point that cheat, you know the look on her face.
And it's funny like sometimes you don't recognize like how bad something is
until you see it in the eyes of someone next to you.
And so when she freaked out and had the look of absolute terror in her eyes,
I kind of just took over the situation because I was 10 seconds ahead of
everyone else. So I yelled to the wife of the boat operator,
whose name is Maria. And I said in a very stern, serious, calm voice,
like marine turn off the boat.
She turned the boat off and I realized that there were two little kids on the
boat. And then the first thought that came to my mind was,
this is something that those kids shouldn't see. Before I came up,
I said, marine, these kids should not see this. You should hide their eyes.
You should distract them. So she took the kids to the front of the boat and uh,
I'm not a real strong person.
I don't know how I got like sudden upper body strength,
but I was able to just pull my full body weight.
I'm thinking I weigh like 210 15 pounds and I just pulled myself up into the
back of the boat and there were my legs.
Layers of fat. I see muscle tissue I'm in.
It's hard to sort of describe like my legs were wide open.
There were big hunks of flesh that have hanging off my leg and the muscles just
sort of, they're exposed to the air. The cuts went down to my bone.
It's like you're at a fish market and you see someone cut into a fish.
You just see the insides like very, very clearly.
And that's when John says like,
get a tourniquet because th the injuries on my legs really looked like it
warranted a tourniquet. And uh, you know,
if I were to ask you to make a tourniquet right now, what would you do?
Like I have no idea who knows how to make a tourniquet right there,
good boy scouts on the boat. So, um,
somebody taking their shirt off and wrapped it around my leg and I said,
look at those towels. And so they wrapped the tiles around my leg and I'm,
what's happening between you and your fiance at that point? Um,
my fiance
thought that I was about to die and she was, you know,
doing all that she could to kind of keep it together.
And I remember looking to her and rubbing her arm and saying,
this is going to be okay. Now is the time for us to be really brave.
This will be okay if for nothing else.
I just wanted to pretend that that was the case cause I didn't really know.
[inaudible]
my name is Colby hall and I survived a fight with a boat propeller,
so he survived.
Turns out the cuts he got was so clean and so deep that it allowed him to heal
more quickly and as an aside,
driving up to Vermont that weekend,
we had stopped at the florist and had this big debate. My wife and I were mind,
she was my fiance at the time, about the color of tablecloths.
You would have thought on the drive up that the single biggest issue in our
lives was the color of tablecloths at the wedding.
It was that the drive back from Vermont after this accident,
you know, we felt so lucky.
Coby hall is a video producer for MTV and this is radio lab.
Today's topic is stress.
What a story it happens that inside that story you've got a classic example of
what always happens in a traumatic situation.
I learned this from one of the leading experts on stretch. Robert Sapolsky.
Do you want me to incorporate your questions,
my answer or just this Roman regular conversation so you can do whatever you
want. Who,
who teaches at Stanford University who pointed out to me that in these
situations,
your body is taken over really by stress hormones.
That's that sort of alert tunnel, vision, time,
passage fields different.
The the eight seconds feel like it took for hours afterward.
Is that what that's about?
It's the stress hormones and that's mostly adrenaline. Doing that you're,
you know,
flailing in the water and hit by an propeller from the boat and your leg is to
severed my imagination. There's two
people in the Dakota, oh my God. Oh my God.
But you say, all right, let's call the police that you somehow are the calm one.
Is that part of this thing?
Often that's the case and that's another piece of the stress response.
You shut down payment
perception. It doesn't really hurt.
Like you would think that was the weird thing. Like it didn't hurt.
Pain is a very subjective state and if it's the right setting,
you blunt a and it's not just guys and battle who've been grievously injured and
they think the blood has been spattered on them from the Gyne and the stump is
just kind of tingling and then they suddenly discover it.
But that's exactly what you do with pain perception.
When you twist your ankle in the company softball game and you hardly even
notice it. So in the face of a major physical stressor,
not only is there this tunnel clarity and sensory, whatever,
there's also blocking of pain. This in the moment,
newness and you know, we all experienced at some point or other.
Where were you when you heard that? When, if Paltrow would named her child,
apple, that sort of thing.
You know those moments that just define our lives and there's a physiology of
it. I know exactly where I was. Where were you?
Um, does he have any idea where that physiology came from? I think he does.
Yeah.
He thinks all mammals have these things in us that we'd gotten from evolution.
So imagine say, Oh, you're a, an impala.
What's an impala? So Antelope Kinda, yeah. So you're,
you're bounding across the sedan. It
[inaudible]. You don't want this tiger to get anywhere near you.
So your insights have to work hard to keep your outsides alive.
You're running for your life, the predators coming after you.
Certain stuff happens. First thing. You need energy,
not energy tucked away in your fat cells for some building project.
Next spring energy right now to go to whichever muscles are going to save your
life, your adrenaline, other hormones. Go to your fat cells.
Pour out all this stored energy, feed it to your thymus.
In addition,
you want to deliver this stuff as fast as possible so you increase your heart
rate.
Another thing you do is you shut down everything.
That's not essential right now. This is no time to worry about hobby collating.
This is no time to worry about growing antlers.
This is no time to digest breakfast. You shut down digestion.
You shut down growth, you shut down reproduction. We all know, for example,
if the digestive and the first step of that and you get nervous,
your mouth gets dry. Everyone has this experience. You go to a,
you have to make a presentation in front of a large number of people.
Maybe just standing there and you're going, there's a burger.
Uh, ladies and gentlemen,
you know that just you can't, if you say the word dog,
your tongue would get stuck at the top of your mouth cause you got nothing going
on wet in your mouth. Your digestive system is shutting down.
And the first step is those fluids that would help you digest upstream beam
aren't there anymore. This is like the antelope. In addition you,
before you do your bowels, you void your bladder as well.
Get rid of the dead weight. That's why people are executed in diapers.
Typically you shut down all these unessentials.
So if you add up all this stuff, if you say, okay,
I'm not growing and I'm thinking faster and my heart is pacing so I can get all
this stuff and I'm, all these things are going on simultaneously.
This is not a bad thing at all. This is a great thing.
It's a great thing if you're stressed like a normal mammal.
So when people talk about stress or stress diseases or being overstressed or the
stressfulness of modern life, what does that mean?
Well almost certainly it means it's got absolutely nothing to do with it.
And with the impala running for its life.
Very few parking spot fights are settled with axes. We don't have to, you know,
wrestle people for canned food items and bombed out supermarkets, our boss. No,
you haven't been to certain sections of New York lately. I know. Rah.
I love people anyway.
When you're actually getting stressed in the way that we talk about in everyday
sense, we're not being physically menaced.
What we're doing is turning on the stress response in anticipation of a
stressor. You mean this literally like you're sitting there in the bed thinking,
Oh God, Oh God, Oh God,
I had this sales meeting tomorrow and you're flushing to your body the same
stress hormones and everything else that will be flooding into the impala.
Dashing being chased by a lion or you mean sorta like that? Yeah, actually,
you know, here's one of these, try it at home exercises, line bed.
When you're nice and sleepy and relaxed and your heart's beating nice and slow,
very carefully. Think you know that heart isn't going to beat forever
and most likely you're going to turn on the exact same stress responses.
If you were running for your life, same hormone, same physiological changes,
same, all of that. Just that, oh my God, one day I'm going to die.
If it really has the right impact on you.
And the punchline of the entire field is that's not what the system evolved for.
[inaudible].
So if you're a human being and you're nervous one and you forget,
scared in the nights in your body,
what's going on that will eventually make you sick. Exactly the same thing.
And all you have to do is that sprint across the savanna kind of writ large and
out of it pops a whole bunch of diseases.
If you're constantly mobilizing energy for those thigh muscles that are
preparing to run you across the Savanna, as you wonder,
is Social Security gonna be there in 30 years if you're constantly doing that
really nervous prison. Yes. Well,
I studied this subject. It's not by chance.
What do you think this was a coin toss? Um,
I worry about being ethnically cleansed by Serbian, you know, roads,
that sort of thing. And I'm sitting here in Palo Alto. Um, you know,
if you constantly mobilize energy, you don't store it.
And for really complex reasons, you're more at risk for this disease.
Adult onset diabetes. This is one of those great diseases that our great,
great grandparents never heard of. A much more accessible versions, you know,
increase your blood pressure out the Wazoo to run for your life.
This is not a big deal for three minutes. Increase it chronically.
Every time you come to work and stress induced hypertension,
you're going to damage the walls of your blood vessels.
No,
not everybody in the world reacts to everything as though they were an antelope
being chased across the Savannah. I mean,
some people can handle all kinds of stress and get through the day and other
people succumb and that's where we ought to go. Next thing coming up,
a particular piece of furniture and its remarkable impact on public health in a
heartwarming tale of a baboon who changed his ways and in the process discovered
the secret to longer life and lower stress. This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad at Boom Rod, Robert Krulwich and I will continue in among.